eventually you guys will see some of
that yeah eventually or getting it
edited right now
um obviously married man oh yeah [ __ ]
you're the man
wow thanks for remembering guys thanks
for remembering it feels like a year ago
holy [ __ ] that was this year yes God
loved getting married so much you did it
three times
obviously yeah gone getting married what
else is there I mean yeah like the fact
that I had diamond on TFT oh yeah
again as we were saying like we did that
trip to uh the states and we finally
filmed trash tanks outside with U.S
guests as well yeah that run was really
good I felt like that that was really
fun and Incredibly satisfying getting to
do so much cool stuff with other
creators yeah I don't know I don't think
any of us had really done anything like
that where we kind of just met a bunch
of cool people and filmed a bunch of
stuff I think that was yeah that was
really nude for us yeah like for me it
felt like if thinking back on the year
the Year for me started in April because
like the earliest big thing I can
remember be like
like the only speak thing I can remember
is like looking because normally we plan
out our entire year right so I remember
looking at the schedule
um and I remember looking at April and
April was when we had planned to film
our road trip special across Japan oh
yeah I was looking at the road trip
special and I was just like when am I
gonna have a free week I don't think I'm
gonna have a free week between April and
November and I pretty much did not you
know I think I've had a free week at all
this year yeah no I'm thinking about it
remember I did have a free week I I was
like Chris let's go cycle across
Hokkaido so you won't agree so I was
like
I see like uh four or three days I'm
like man I should I should uh I should
do something yeah fill it up with
something yeah even though like it's
it's for the most part A lot of the
times it's completely unnecessary no I
mean like I just I'm always itching to
do something I feel like oh man I you
know it's bad I think uh it's a bad
habit it's a good habit because like
sometimes it's like we work so hard and
you know and I think we rarely get to
sometimes take a moment and enjoy
ourselves but that's the thing right
it's like I'm gonna go travel let's do
something yeah yeah but that's the thing
it's like every time I see like even
like three days just like back to back
to back free yeah my head there's like
The Logical side of me that's like oh I
should probably fill this up with
something to do you know some work
related things and then the child side
of me is like I start a new jrpg right
now probably finish it and then The
Logical side at the adult side of me
always [ __ ] wins I'm like yeah
another week gone just like that I love
playing album ring so much this year it
was so fun it was so good it was so good
yeah I like dead ass don't remember some
months like just some months are just
like March I don't remember what the
[ __ ] we did March we were filming ahead
to March was just all filming yeah right
that's probably why I don't remember it
you know what let's look at the calendar
I'm glad I have my calendar uh and I
literally put everything in my calendar
now it's my my God if it's not in the
calendar I will forget it let's go let's
go let's go
oh my god oh man yeah no this was a lot
of filming for me yeah okay now we
filmed the road oh wait this is April
hold on uh March is what are we doing
March let's see oh we did the charity
stream in March oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ] that
was this year yeah yeah oh my God and
then we also went to a bunch of
conventions as well yeah yeah the first
time I went to Trio as a trio for the
first time and it was also like our
first post pandemic convention which is
insane and it was an experience oh yeah
that we were not prepared for I don't
think I was out of Bedford no I I really
really really liked cons a lot and then
after this I was kind of like I think I
like cons a little less yeah I think it
was like I think uh like I think we
mentioned this as well like we're just
like yeah I think um we said this in the
previous episode where it was like yeah
it's kind of up to the point now where
it's like a little too big yeah not to
be like I'm such a big [ __ ] deal it's
like can't you know can't really enjoy
them the way I used to yeah yeah it's
like going around it's gotten to the
point where you just can't enjoy
conventions for conventions
unfortunately
um which which makes me sad because I do
love walking the artist alley and stuff
like that I do love just walking around
the conventions taking it maybe going to
a random panel you know I remember doing
that and unfortunately that just wasn't
possible for us at any convention that
we went to this year yeah
um you know maybe maybe I'll fall off
maybe I'll maybe we'll like L plus ratio
sometime soon yeah right but I've put
our careers on the line so we can walk
the honest alley again it seems like a
train
I'm like man there's just been a i I'd
say it's been a pretty great year yeah
it's been it's been a pretty great year
absolutely and I feel like we've
definitely this year has been like such
a big focus on trash taste even more
than previous years even though we like
focus on our personal channels and stuff
previous years as well I feel like this
year with the conventions with the tour
with the specials we've done and
everything like that it's just this year
I saw these boys faces a lot even more
than before so
odds thank God I actually you like we
were actually really good [ __ ]
friends yeah because this year was the
real tester of that you know yeah this
is like the three-year limit you know
that every couple goes through it's like
if we go after the three year mark I
think we're pretty cool yeah yeah we had
a lot of questions on tour and people
asked us they're like man you guys you
guys have any like arguments falling out
I'm like wow I don't know not really
kind of kind of pretty good at knowing
how to like hang out yeah I feel like
we've been friends so long now where
it's like we just get each other yeah I
know that we don't let it devolve into
an argument I mean it was even even like
I was surprised at how like weird not
not how weird but how
uneventful just like the the bus
experience was in terms of like when I
say uneventful just like like in a
negative sense yeah it was just like
nothing really happened that there was
no tension no drama no like not even
like slight annoyances you know it was
just a very pleasant experience and
people were just like yo spill the the
tea what happened on tour school and see
and I'm just like who's hating who yeah
yeah and I'm just like nothing really
happened I I feel bad because it always
sounds like a cop-out to be like no we
just got along really well and no one's
like no there must be something there
must be something yeah and I'm just like
I'm I'm like reaching when I'm like
Connor would not stop playing TFT and it
annoyed the marker he flooded his room
because of TFT actually which was an
actual problem
there's no bearing on you guys yeah yeah
yeah
um yeah like because like we got along
with the staff uh all the shows went
really well everyone would chill I think
we're just chill guys I think I think we
we don't expect sorry sorry I'm so chill
guys if like we're on the same bus I
don't feel the need that I need God's
attention or need to like talk to Joey
all the time it's kind of like oh
because I'm talking about it yeah are
you thinking yeah have you had that
question from like personal friends and
stuff or you're just like oh what
happened on tour and you're like oh
nothing much yeah and then they go no
what really no nothing nothing I'm like
no really nothing my own sister asked me
that she was like so did you guys like
fight on the boss I'm like what the [ __ ]
no
no well I always go on tour with people
I would go and get in a fight with stop
boxing yeah just punch the [ __ ] out of
each other yeah yeah no I mean like yeah
I think the the tour especially like
everything we wanted to go well went
well and yeah you know as boring as it
sounds for for the drama channels we
literally nothing happened